car tester Reinhold doesn't over asserts
that if a family wants to drive
cross-country they should have the
ability the great success of models like
the Passat Alltrack and the Audi Allroad
made it only a matter of time before VW
put out a golf with all-wheel drive and
off-road capabilities and here it is the
new golf all track looking back we see
there has already been an all-wheel
drive golf the golf to country in 1990
but at the time nobody wanted it now 25
years later given the SUV boom it
doesn't take a psychic to predict this
attempt will sell far better
VW's new golf for off-road driving
follows the current trend with flared
side skirts fake skid plates and black
trim this station wagon certainly looks
ready for the rough the old track also
comes with two extra centimetres ground
clearance larger tires and 4motion
all-wheel drive the Haldex coupling
prevents wheel spin if the rear wheel
starts spinning in uneven terrain within
seconds the force is shifted to the
front wheels our car tester is amazed at
what the golf whole track can do off the
road normally what only full-fledged
SUVs can manage through driving mode and
the all-wheel drive distribute the force
between the front and rear axles from
zero to 100% that makes for perfect grip
on snow slush ice gravel or sand in the
off-road driving mode the car can really
handle rough terrain and steep inclines
driving down steep slopes can be
nerve-wracking but with the hill descent
assist the driver just has to work up
the courage to let off the brakes only
then can the engine management systems
do their job properly the range of
diesel engines available is led by the
one in our test car the 135 kilowatt 2.0
TDI it carries the all track from 0 to
100 km/h in 7.8 seconds reaching a
maximum speed of 219 km/h Volkswagen
rates fuel consumption at an average of
5 liters per 100 kilometers this model
starts at 30,000 200 euros in Germany
yo VW's alfred Metzl says the Passat
variant Alltrack has already shown that
this concept works the variant all track
offers a genuine alternative to the SUV
concepts a vehicle with full off-road
capabilities for people who don't
necessarily want to drive in SUV but
would like to have the practicality and
versatility of a station wagon
thoroughly rework to stress the
ruggedness the new all track makes a
suitably robust impression while it's
still unmistakeably a golf but the
differences are immediately apparent the
front and rear have both been restyled
and fitted with bold fashions bumpers
with silver coloured skid plates in
front and back the all track has a
unique honeycomb grille black enlarged
wheel arches and the silver matte flared
side skirts following the principle
never change a winning team the all
track has the accustomed golf interior
these nine holt wonders how much
off-road a person needs to judge by the
sales figures for SUVs and all-wheel
drive vehicles it must be a lot but why
not
modern all-wheel drive cars hardly take
any more fuel but offer greater safety
and versatility the new golf all track
combines reliability and variability
with very good off-road capabilities but
at a price the base version costs a
minimum of thirty thousand euros